bonsoir
ce jeu suit
désolé en soit je n'avais pas vraiment
envie de venir ici ce soir parce que
j'avais peur de vous mais surtout de
l'image que j'allais refléter de l'image
qui elle est figée ici ce soir je ne
voulais pas être associés comme le
stéréotype du conférencier tedx et ce
problème là m'a fait penser à un autre
problème que j'avais déjà rencontré pour
palima dépression j'ai interprété des
personnages des méchants des gens qui
sont exclus de la société
c'était des stéréotypes de personnes
qu'on rencontre dans le cinéma noir dans
l'est les anti héros dans les romans
j'ai tour à tour été pirates punk à
chien libraire mines parisien bourgeoise
surréaliste cancre espions secret
postiers jaloux sirène édenté et diable
une fois j'ai même été en fantôme
je vais vous raconter son histoire ce
soir il s'appelle eustache et l'histoire
commence lors d'une partie de cache
cache
ils allaient se cacher dans un placard
un endroit qui connaissait assez bien le
problème c'est que personne n'est venu
le trouver
personne n'est venu le délivrer mais je
crois que personne n'avait vraiment
envie de le trouver et n'avait pas assez
de force
pas assez de courage pour ouvrir la
porte il s'est laissé mourir ici comment
je le sais parce que j'étais à côté de
lui j'ai vu son corps son cadrage et son
fantôme j'ai décidé d'ouvrir la porte du
placard pour nous deux pour son salut
est ce que j'ai vu dehors m'a vraiment
fait peur m'a angoissé
j'ai vite compris que le flot incessant
d'image n'allait pas s'arrêter pour que
je prenne le temps de les intégrer que
le monde n'allait pas s'arrêter de faire
des images
je pense que c'est à ce moment là où
j'ai commencé à faire de la photographie
cela me permettait de créer une distance
entre le réel émoi le monde et moi de
créer un cocon une sorte de bouée de
sauvetage qui me permettent de revenir
son nom réel de le séquencé
j'aime avais je m'étais trouvé une
famille j'étais devenu un méchant mais
c'était une famille s est fictive
du coup j'ai décidé de m'intéresser aux
personnes qui étaient réellement rejetés
par la société les personnes marginales
j'ai conscience que dans cette série
jean ferme les gens dans leurs
stéréotypes
c'est à dire que une personne tatoués de
la tête aux pieds je la prends en photo
parce que justement elle est tatouée de
la tête aux pieds
mais en un sens je lui donne une
visibilité une reconnaissance une
histoire et dans cette boulimie d'image
il est peut-être important de comprendre
un des mécanismes fondamentaux des
images ce soir je vais vous révéler ce
secret il s'appelle intérêts coni cité
je tiens ce ce mot d'un auteur qui
s'appelle clément chéroux dans son
ouvrage intitulé diplopie dans celui ci
il explique que les images sont avant
tout politiques
pourquoi parce que lors de l'attentât du
vol trade center à 41% près les images
qui sont qui ont été les plus utilisés
dans les journaux dans les médias c'est
l'image des twin towers en fumée
pourquoi cette image
il explique que trois mois plus tôt est
sorti dans les salles le film pearl
harbor dans ce film on peut voir
l'amérique en feu en flammes et dans
cette fiction on comprend que l'amérique
est en guerre l'intericonicité c'est ça
c'est d'utiliser une image qui a déjà
été accepté par la société avec un sens
pour l'appliquer le calquer sur une
autre image avec sept îles à sion de
sens je me suis intéressé si toutes les
images de notre société avait cet
intérêt coni site est là et par exemple
sur instagram
il est beaucoup plus facile pour
quelqu'un une jeune fille par exemple
d'utiliser les codes qui sont déjà créés
par exemple par une icône comme kim
kardashian de les reprendre et se faire
accepter par la société ici le sens et
je suis aussi belle je suis aussi
désirable que kim kardashian je mérite
le même nombre de like
et je me suis intéressé aux images qui
étaient les plus tabous de notre société
à savoir les images pornographiques
je me suis inscrit sur des sites de
rencontres des blogs des sites pornos et
j'ai demandé aux gens de m'envoyer les
images qu'ils faisaient qu'ils
envoyaient sur ces sites là dans cet
esprit de consommation et un jour j'ai
reçu une image d'un homme nu dans son
salon très bien décorée à côté d'un
sapin de noël et ça m'a choqué ça n'a
choqué parce que dans cet élan de
consommation de l'image ici par
intericonicité il associe deux idées
l'idée de la pornographie et l'idée du
père noël qui est par sa proximité avec
les enfants asexuée du coup j'ai assisté
là à une nouvelle image que j'avais
jamais vu
on pourrait l'appeler archétypes et de
cette forme archétypale je voulais voir
si il en découlait des stéréotypes un
archétype je voudrais le prendre comme
la première forme d'une image convoi qui
va du coup conditionné toutes les autres
et ma conclut ce que j'en ai conclu
c'est que oui il ya bien la récré est
fort la recréation de ses codes
pourquoi cette interview citée est
dangereuse parce qu elle uniformise les
réseaux elle est aussi dangereuse parce
qu'il a une idéalisation de l'image et
je pense que comme eustache le fantôme
il faudrait sortir de ce régime
fantasmagorique envers les images ici
d'ailleurs ce soir
tout n'était que mise en scène tout
n'était qu'un énorme mensonge comme on
fait aux enfants pour noël
j'aimerais aller plus loin dans ses
représentations et imaginé avec vous un
monde sans images
on s'arrête un peu compliqué parce que
tout le monde a je pense déjà fait des
images et tout le monde est devenu déjà
venu avec des images préconçues
dans sa tête mais imaginons une
plateforme
imaginons instagram cette place
on serait totalement vierge c'est à dire
qu'il n'y aurait pas de contenu sur le
réseau dense on n'y aurait pas d'image
qui est déjà préconçues sur le compte et
pas d'image sur son feed donc pas
d'image pour alimenter celui ci
imaginons que ce soir j'ai créé ce
contenu pour vous je vous donne ici les
codes de cette install g j'aimerais que
tous ici vous puissiez faire durant
cette soirée des photos et les poster
sur cet instant g là ça peut être
maintenant ça peut être après est ce
qu'il va être intéressant à voir c'est
si vous allez regarder les voisins les
photos que vous vous en ont déjà posté
c'est des images qui vont avoir des
laïcs ou non s'il va y avoir une méthode
d'archivage avec des hashtag je vous
laisse totalement libres 2 merci d'avoir
écouté
bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]